in this season
yes spending your time people
so I got here I'm sitting on this stage
right this second because people are the
only asset in business
[Music]
so all my Juggernaut billionaire fancy
friends always get mad at me when I
start talking about feelings in business
empathy come passion you know I'm also
not eighth place trophy guy in a world
where everyone's falling in love with
being all red or all blue I'm purple as
[__] and so I believe in kindness I
believe that nice guys finish first I
believe in patience I believe in empathy
I believe in good people skills it
matters but I also believe in tenacity
and work ethic I spend my time on people
I'm dming back people I'm reading all
the comments because that's how I get
research I'm meeting with clients I'm
meeting with my employees I would argue
that I'm more in the HR department than
I'm in the CEO role I'm with my people
and when you build a family you have
continuity